we are expecting the fda to approve a
second vaccine for emergency use
it could happen just hours from now this
comes after modernist coronavirus
vaccine won a near unanimous
recommendation yesterday
from an fda advisory panel now after
official approval if it comes nearly 6
million doses could be shipped around
the country as soon as next week now the
modern
vaccine does not require the ultra cold
storage
that the pfizer vaccine does that's good
news also in trials
94 percent effective our lead national
correspondent david begnow is in san
bernardino county that's just outside
los angeles david
good morning to you this almost sounds
like a typo california is apparently at
zero percent
icu beds remaining what does that even
mean
well take arrowhead where we are this
morning tony they have no icu beds
available
so people who need icu care are being
held and treated in the emergency room
and people who are coming to the er are
being triaged outside
and inside those tents that are lit up
behind me
that's what's happening here they have
128 patients
covet patients in the hospital right now
behind me that's the highest one day
total they've had
over the course of the entire pandemic
and they gave us
exclusive access inside to take a look
so you could see exactly what's
happening
it's a healthy 33 year old huh yes sir
right now there is not a single
available icu bed at arrowhead regional
medical center
as the unrelenting crush of covet
patients
is simply pushing staff to their limits
listen to this nurse
we're at the point where we no longer
could take care of them the wait is a
lot longer
you know the patients are really sick
with no beds inside
patients are now being triaged and
treated in tents
outside and then there are the front
line workers like albert almadore
he is a custodian at arrowhead every day
wrapped head to toe in ppe he cleans
and cares for the rooms that house the
covic patients
i wonder what you think when you're in
there cleaning and the patient is there
i pray for the patients as i clean but
for hospitals like arrowhead there is
more help on the way
in the form of a second vaccine this
time from moderna
yesterday the fda's independent panel
and vaccines
endorsed the modern vaccine for
emergency use
dr eric rubin is a member of that group
what should people take away from the
panels
nearly unanimous yes i think the
important message
is that the panelists felt very
confident
in the vaccine and these are going to be
some of the first people in line to get
the vaccine themselves and give it to
their families
you know all week we have noticed
enthusiasm from frontline workers
who were either giving the pfizer
vaccine to their colleagues or receiving
it
it was like you were giving them a shot
of gold they were just so excited about
it
for this nurse in lafayette louisiana it
was giving the vaccine
that was the real gift on thursday she
was able to vaccinate the oncologist
that she says helped save her life when
she was diagnosed
with breast cancer he saved my life
20 years ago and me giving him this
injection today
i hopefully could help save his for me
to be able to sit with the man
who sued me comforted me gave me
hope and here i had in my hands
hope for him that louisiana nurse is my
mother
sid bagno she's a retired nurse but she
now works part-time
looking after the health and safety of
other front-line workers and
i'm so proud of her because i know for
her it was giving back in terms of
giving the shot but it was also paying
it forward
as a former patient because it was a
real
full circle moment for her full circle
moment indeed david that was a great
story before i even knew it was your mom
that was so great
and for you to be interviewing your
mother too very nice
very nice thank you yeah i'm sure you
know what she's proud of you too
thank you very much